we turn now to an amazing series of
investigative reports from the
non-profit journalism group propublica
documenting how some of america's
super-rich have been able to avoid
paying taxes for years rhonda
and it comes on the very week that most
of us have had to file our tax returns
and send a check to the irs
we're joined now by paul keel a reporter
at propublica part of the 10-person team
which used old-fashioned shoe leather
reporting excellent sources and some
incredible documents to reveal just how
america's super wealthy have been able
to pretty much avoid the taxman paul
thanks for being here what in a sense
did you find bottom line about america's
super rich
well the thing that really struck us uh
was that how little they pay
particularly when you compare to how
much they're worth that is that is the
thing that
was the first thing we noticed and then
uh
took real pains to explain to people you
know how how that is possible
but it's all legal
that i would there are some lines that
there's some blurry lines uh in the tax
world they talk about aggressive tax
planning
um
we saw some aggressive tax planning um
you know one example is peter thiel
billionaire was able to amass five
billion dollars in a roth ira account a
retirement account designed for the
middle class
is now also a tax-free piggy bank for
some of the wealthiest americans
how
turning a roth ira into a giant tax
shelter
first here's how a roth works you invest
a limited amount of money each year and
once the money is in the account it's
never taxed again as long as you don't
withdraw it before age 59 and a half
here's an example in 1999 before he
became a billionaire paypal founder
peter thiel had a roth ira worth less
than 2 000
20 years later his roth had grown to
more than 5 billion
the biggest account we found he won't
have to pay tax on a penny of that and
he can start to collect tax-free six
years from now
that was something that was
a great line that he might have crossed
um but a lot of this yeah it's just the
way that our tax system is set up it's
not that it's not set up to tax wealth
to set up the tax a specific definition
of income
how about some of the super rich like
michael bloomberg
yeah bloomberg really came across as
paying a remarkably low tax rate so uh
around an average of four percent
a lot of that has to do with deductions
he's able to take he's you know he gives
a lot of charitable deductions um and
then there's there's just deductions in
our tax code that uh that he's able to
write off a lot of his income
and jeff bezos of amazon yeah bezos
stuck us as someone who
has been largely successful and not
you know he's massively wealthy based on
his his holdings in amazon but for the
large part he's he's avoided turning
that into the sort of income that ends
up on a tax returns today today was also
tax day or as jeff bezos calls it no
it's not
now if you procrastinate on your taxes
you're not alone as of last week 40 of
this year's taxpayers were still
unaccounted for
with many scrambling to submit their
documents today in fact google's top
search term today was what is 1099 how
to get face transplant and move to
mexico tonight jeff bezos is so good at
hiding his wealth that he qualified for
a child tax credit
this dude built his own rocket to take
him to space and the u.s government is
like hey brother here's something for
the kids until you can get back on your
feet
hard times jeff so
one key stat for him is over the time
period 2014 to 2018
he grew 100 billion dollars richer
and managed to only pay about a billion
dollars in tax during that time which is
a rate of about a one percent
one percent and the average american
pays what percent those who get their
money through w-tunes
right so we give examples of even
someone earning like forty five thousand
dollars a year
who earns all their money through their
wages can end up paying if you can
include both income tax and payroll
taxes around twenty percent
in your headline you say if you're
getting a w-2 you're a sucker what do
you mean by that
i mean because
for normal people what your income is is
not really much of a question it's a
sort of an obvious thing to ask and you
get a piece of paper
every every year that says what your
income was but what income is to the
wealthy is a much more uh
flexible thing i guess i would say and
so like at the example of bezos
you can control what you turn into
income so you control you know how much
income you put in your tax return each
year essentially and then there's a lot
of a lot more uh opportunities to
generate
uh expenses losses that can wipe out
income on your tax returns so we have
examples of billionaires who end up with
uh incomes on their tax returns that
have something like negative 400 million
for example it's not a reflection of
their actual situation it's a reflection
of what they're able to do through taxes
your team also took a deep dive looking
at the billionaire owners of sports
teams let's look at one of the graphics
the team prepared
[Music]
[Applause]
this is billionaire steve ballmer he
owns the la clippers
he pays a way lower tax rate than
millionaire lebron james
he even pays a lower rate than adelaide
avila a stadium worker
[Music]
he's basically dunking on the tax system
welcome to planet tax avoidance
this is a magical place where sports
team owners can tell the government they
make tens or even hundreds of millions
less than they actually do and pay very
little in taxes
and it's all perfectly legal
so
you know with a basic
situation where if you own a sports team
there's this thing in the tax code this
is legal it's way set up as a break that
they got put in
uh even as the if the sports team is
doing really well earning a lot of money
you can deduct it you can basically
deduct the cost of buying it over time
so it generates massive tax losses even
for people who are making money off
their teams meanwhile they're players
people like lebron james
they're getting their
their compensation form of wages which
is taxed at the top rate
so they pay a far higher tax rate than
the owners
and the secretaries in the office
more than secretaries in office i think
we give an example of someone who works
in the stadium uh they're just paying
they have w2 they're paying wages
they're paying uh sorry they're paying
income taxes they're paying payroll
taxes it's all pretty straightforward so
how is your team able to get the
documents which essentially show the
taxes paid by some of these super rich
americans
we obtained the information we were
sending it was sent to us uh we spent a
long time
trying to verify it
and it was after we'd done years of
coverage on the irs and how it'd been
weakened by budget cuts
and it was a massive amount of data it
was a massive
uh task just to organize it and then to
make sense of it and taxes of course
were so complicated so it was a real
it was a real challenge to and then to
boil it down for people in a way they
could understand it that was clear
your team did an amazing job of
untangling all that do you think any of
this is going to lead to changes in the
tax code
well we had some things did come out of
it so i mentioned peter thiel and his
massive roth ira there was legislation
on the hill to deal with that
um some of this these loss generating
tactics there was some legislation on
the table the problem is that nothing
really is passing on the hill right now
uh biden had a proposal that would have
taxed uh unrealized gains so it would
have gotten at this problem of people
like bezos not having an income on their
tax return so there are solutions to
this their solutions talked about this
in dc
but in terms of it actually passing
you know who what passes in dc these
days i don't know
so as it stands now some of those same
tax breaks or most of those same tax
breaks are still in law nothing's really
changed unfortunately
well you did a fantastic job hats off to
you and your team for an amazing uh
series of reports all right thank you
up next this week's winners and losers
in the media what's going on at netflix
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aide mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media group and aiden
you've chosen as your winner this week a
changing in the guard at the new york
times a new person in the top job
perhaps the most influential job in
american journalism
that's right so for the first time in
eight years we have a new top editor of
the new york times his name is joe kahn
and he's a fairly unassuming presence
at the times he's had an incredible
career there picked up two pulitzer
prizes for his reporting um and served
as a correspondent in beijing for the
paper then it's international editor and
then it's managing editor for the past
couple years serving as number two under
dean bakay who has been executive editor
of the new york times for the past eight
years uh steering the paper through
astonishing growth
and also several controversies
now dean mckay is 65 years old this year
that means that he's at uh the
unofficial mandatory retirement age for
new york times executive editors um so
dean mckay is going to be retiring as
executive editor in june he will be
replaced by joe khan but he's not
retiring entirely from the paper
a.g saltzberger who is the
publisher of the new york times said
that dean mckay is going to have a
surprising an exciting new role
at the paper when he eventually uh
allows joe khan to take over uh in the
top editor position and fair to say joe
khan is the old guard at the times
yeah i think that's really what the buzz
has been uh
this week about this appointment is that
joe khan is a traditional times uh
editor in fact he's exactly what you
would imagine
an editor of an elite institution like
the new york times
has always been
he went to harvard
he got a job at the new york times uh 25
years ago and worked his way up the
ladder at the times over the course of
uh more than two decades
he's also the son of the co-founder of
staples
so he not only went to
an elite school served at an elite
institution like the new york times he's
also from from considerable wealth so
this is a fairly traditional selection
for the new york times which is
interesting because
of how much change the paper has gone
through in the last decade
and for a loser this week you've chosen
the top man at netflix reed hastings who
had to make some sobering announcements
to his stockholders sending the shares
way down here's what he had to say
disney is going to be a global service
uh you know quite quickly
and there are many other global services
remember that we compete a lot for time
with youtube um and it's not dollars
because that's deported but you know we
compete very broadly for uh viewing and
as spence mentioned our viewing on a per
member basis is up they happen to have
they have not monetized 500 million
viewers i mean what are they thinking
what are they thinking that we won't
watch an ad to see who wins in squid
games
that they have these programs ozark they
could like flood they mean the state of
missouri would probably run ads they
sponsor it but they're so uncreative and
they're so dogmatic that their their own
i mean on the conference call it was
really sad
because it was like you know
we thought we were doing well
we're not
your sister's the fault
your cousin
i blame your sharing password
so aidan the long knives are out for
netflix and i guess for mr hastings
that's true so reid hastings uh who has
uh you know heretofore been considered
uh
one of the most impenetrable ceos of any
company in netflix considered to be a
true titan of streaming
announced this week that for the first
time uh in more than a decade they have
actually lost subscribers i have here
the numbers cnn reported
that uh the company's stock had had
already dropped this year more than 40
percent
and it plummeted uh 35 on wednesday
morning which wiped out
50 billion dollars in market cap for
netflix
now that stock uh plummeting is the
result of the uh the service losing uh
200 000 subscribers in the first quarter
of 2022. now that doesn't sound like a
lot because the company has 221 million
global subscribers but it's actually
fairly significant because it's the
first time in 10 years that netflix has
regressed in its growth
this means a lot of different things for
netflix
it also means that reid hastings who has
said for years that he does not want
advertising on his service is
reconsidering things like that um so it
marks a big change for netflix and a big
change for streaming going forward so
high-flying netflix uh brought down to
earth
yeah it brought down earth considerably
and and you know they're they're having
to reconsider these things uh like
advertising they're probably going to be
offering a
cheaper version of netflix that allows
advertising on it you'll be able to pay
a premium to not have ads on netflix
that's something that reid hastings
never considered before previously so it
really shows how much the company is
rattled by this news all right thank you
so much aid mclaughlin for being here
and thanks to all of you for joining us
that's our program for tonight we'll see
you back here again next week
you